Tung tâm sự báo khi tự thị văn cuốc gia cho biết từ 2.5 đĩnh gẩn bị chiến tháng 5,
gió anh vượn của không khi lại nền sánh át thấp kích hợp vùng hội tụ sò trên cào.
Cô vực bắt bộ và thành hoa sẽ có mưa vừa.
Mưa tò, con ơi mưa rất tò với tổng lượng mưa phổ biến 8.5 đĩnh 8.5 đĩnh 8.5 đĩnh 9.5
một số nơi trên 1 trăm tảm mềm y lì mấy.
Tương nghĩa anh đến hà tính, một số thiện vụn hơn, bắt đầu từ ngày 8.5 đĩnh 8.5,
lượng mưa phổ biến 4.5 đĩnh 7.5, con ơi vượn 1 trăm 5.5.
Càng báo nguy cơ sức hiện mưa cơ sất lớn trên 1 trăm mì lì mấy trong bòng bà dơ,
giế gây ngập uống cuộc bộ tại vùng chúng thấp.
Giò mưa lớn cào dài nhiều ngày trước đó, các khu vực bùng lối tự bắt bộ đến hà tính có nguy cơ cao
sẽ ra lũ quách sật lợ đất, ngập uống đô thị và nông thuật.
Được mưa cào dài, tương nghĩa 2.5 đĩnh 2.5 đứa tháng 5,
và qua đáp hiện nhiều địa phương ở hà tính chữ thiệt thải nắng gió mưa lũ bất thường trong tháng 5.
Người ngập uống trên diễn giọc, ai ngửa biến 3 mầu, bất nguy và đổi sống nhân dân.